thank you see I got the most all-purpose
on Super Bowl history whatever but it
don't bother me because I was like doing
his coaching like man you are coaching
that land college now what some people
they don't matter like riding a bike man
[Applause]
Jacoby we talking about the playoffs you
had a great playoff run in 2012 while
you remember with the Baltimore Ravens
right you become a legend with the
Mahavira cool
following week y'all beat the Patriots
got a filing at the Super Bowl and your
home you in New Orleans the first thing
I thought was I'm going on I didn't play
that don't plenty of time I played an
all-star do all in his all-star game in
there I was comfortable like I was like
my mama cooked for the whole team so we
landed he walked into the ballroom
food right yeah Wow get your play oh
[ __ ] I didn't know I'm a bad man trying
to take t take me through the beginning
of that game the first ball Joe threw me
I'm drunk it's when I got him who did
like this my banjo my bad
old I did you end up scoring a touchdown
take me through what happened there Joey
I guess here I got pressured or whatever
when so as you like to catch the ball
first
boom I'm like dude and touch my god if I
say oh I looked at the pylons I'm on the
racing to the pylon when I see my man is
coming I said yeah anybody hit me
brother he hit hard
- the shot goes boy he hit hard your
thumb flying up I'm like boy stop
but then you get to the ears Oh what
does that move you here hey what was it
it's all new or I flew back into G ok ok
ok you get the bean away Rosa like for
you to do that
that's a super dog there's so many
athletes in New Orleans they don't get a
shot so I felt like I was showing them
anybody can make it out this city it was
a dope moment and the Ravens were able
to build up some momentum you're going
to halftime with the lead Beyonce's
perform are you paying attention to
coach he paints it I got it yep I got
coming out that locker room what happen
you come out there I'm in my zone I'm
bouncing I'm running off racy come in
pink oh my [ __ ] they put their plan and
I told him I said coach they recall this
play okay how deeper this you got to let
me come up my xcode he's ok GUI I said
subtract me first write down the pike I
seen two six behind when I seen him ease
up Luke to the sideline is hit watch
this race down the side laughter you hit
this after you score you hit touched it
touched it he will talk about not really
my dog on me the various librational
Percy me you not a leader
me the truth after
anybody on the sideline throwing up
never liked school the plumber turn
power turn I am coming
come look a new whole life went up on
each side
not outside born and raised from Rosa
never in the history of America I've
never seen the lights go out in the
Superdome
first the lights and go outgoing Katrina
in the Superdome everybody stay focused
a lot of more stretching doing all that
but mentors playing pre-tape once you
come back from that third quarter then
Kaepernick come back they start making
this a game what's going on to your mind
as you start seeing that lead window
down
so one possession will be my man all my
life I had to fight blows so as the
clocks turn triple zero a Super Bowl
champion where are you going what is
going on here so I just fell to my knees
thank God is a grandmas son I kissed Amy
I guess just was a blessing man Joe
Flacco won Super Bowl MVPs and that
Super Bowl but you were bawling that
game there's a lot of people that
thought you were the real MVP they don't
it still don't bother me I got the most
all-purpose dogs and all that then Super
Bowl history whatever but it don't
bother me because I win it home how many
people say they want a super born in the
city I'm good my theater gave me the
cove hit them around the city the core
no I just winning at home with enough
for me I'm gonna take my pony go ahead
make it three points you know take it to
bingo free throw
food drew thanks for kicking it with us
subscribe to be our to check out more
dope videos like this one